And there's a lot of people who are for
them and a lot of people are against
them.
It seems that most of the people who
are,
four of them are essentially ip holding
companies who just sit around and wait
with patents and wait until technology
actually gets interesting using
something that could potentially be
covered by these patents.
And then they sue people and they don't
generally,
they don't sue smaller companies.
They sue,
Microsoft and IBM and of course IBM and,
you know,
like all these big companies have their
own patents pools and they use them as
leverage against other companies with
patents.
Uh,
but I just,
you know,
I think there are so many problems with
it.
Uh,
the biggest problems are that you have
people patenting and things that are
essentially math,
which is what patents are not supposed
to be even about at all.
Um,
and the,
I mean,
there are other problems.
There are no,
it's,
I'm usually drunk when I give this
explanation and it comes out so much
smoother.
Um,
I,
I just think that there are a big
problem,
uh,
largely because,
you can infringe on them without knowing
that you do and as a smaller company you
have like,
very,
you don't have resources to go and
research whether or not you do it.
It's,
I could write a 100,000 lines of code
and for all I know 50,000 women fringe
on various things.
Um,
and I wouldn't know that.
And normally if you infringe someone's
trademark,
for example,
um,
if they don't enforce it,
uh,
it's to your advantage because a phase
they start to lose their rights.
Whereas patents,
if they don't enforce it for 10 years,
they can come and sue you for the 10
years that you've been making money on
their patent and you're completely
screwed.
So there's no incentive for them to
actually go and,
and,
uh,
try to legitimately licensed it.
It's really the kind of thing where
there are probably,
there's probably some middle ground
where,
uh,
it makes sense to have things be
patentable.
Um,
obviously in many places it does make
sense,
but things like software and people
patenting DNA,
it's,
uh,
it's at the point where you have things
that are so abstract that they really
should belong to everybody and no one's
really like making viable businesses on
software patents.
The only thing they're doing is
extorting money out of other people.
Um,
and the people who have the most
software patents probably don't even
want them to exist.
They're just forced to do it to cover
their own asses.